the new battle lines in the culture war
at least for the last 48 hours have
become
dr seuss now i'm going to play a bunch
of clips for you
if you haven't been following the latest
fake scandal
it is indeed dr seuss the children's
author
republicans are claiming that dr seuss
has been banned
cancelled in particular by a virginia
school district now first of all the
story
is all based on a claim that's not true
read across america day is a day of
reading children's books historically
it had lots of dr seuss material in 2017
this
changed to be more diverse in 2019 a
study looked at dr
seuss's books and found that characters
of color are very underrepresented they
make up only two percent of the human
characters and that almost all of those
representations of minority characters
uh play
on stereotypical tropes and portrayals
in particular
of asians and that's true there's no
question about that whatsoever
of course dr seuss books written in a
different era but there is no denying
that that is absolutely the case
so the virginia school district they
didn't ban dr seuss
they didn't burn any books they did
decide
not to connect read across america day
to dr
seuss specifically now some people were
happy
some people were not but dr seuss wasn't
banned dr
seuss wasn't canceled this is now
the issue to the right in fighting
this cancel culture war that is totally
trumped up and fabricated
and they are getting an insane amount of
mileage from it yesterday this is just a
few hours on fox news
okay think about everything that's been
going on in the world in the last 24
hours
and look at how much the story was dr
seuss on fox news
here is congressman jason chaffetz
appearing on fox to express
outrage jason jason where do you come
down give us 30 seconds
well i haven't gotten past the
assassination of mr potato head
that that one i still haven't gotten
past and now they're trying to take out
dr
seuss come on john these are these are
the icons i grew up with
yes fox ran a major segment during this
hour called
cancel culture comes for dr seuss
a fox news reporter asked biden press
secretary jen
saki about dr seuss kristen give another
question question
about dr seuss it's maybe the only david
you can bring up dr seuss
uh it is national read across america
day it's also dr seuss's birthday
both former presidents obama and trump
mentioned dr seuss in their
read across america day proclamations
but president biden did not why not
fox news characterized this portion of
the press briefing to stir up even more
controversy
by captioning it quote biden whitehouse
dodge's question on dr seuss
later in the day fox news tried to stir
up
more controversy by pointing out that
barack obama
once praised dr seuss let me just quote
barack obama in 2015 saying
quote pretty much all the stuff you need
to know is in dr
seuss now is barack obama racist for for
quoting dr
seuss there and and patting him on the
back for the work can i add one
i don't think so one other angle to this
there are so many kids right now who are
falling behind in their
reading because of this it's a great
place to start they're not in the
classroom and dr
seuss this company could be just
spreading that message
educate our children encourage literacy
um interesting stuff david it's good
enough for barack obama it's good enough
for me and the rest of america i think
then they do another segment on dr seuss
referring
uh to the um demand of congressman jim
jordan
to do congressional hearings on cancel
cancel culture vis-a-vis dr seuss
sports is also with us as well and john
from the political state this has gotten
this has gotten political
right because jim jordan has now stepped
in he's saying that there's a dangerous
trend happening with
canceled culture in this country he's
now calling on congress to examine this
canceled culture
that he says is sweeping america
you know everything is political these
days you know whether it's woke culture
whether it's cancer
culture or whether it's extreme on
either side here but
in the morning yesterday they had
reporter or anchor or
i don't know what role she is carly
shimkas reporting
that six dr seuss books will no longer
be published and have been
cancelled now it is true but it's dr
seuss enterprises that decided for
itself
that as a business decision these six
books contain
hurtful stereotypical portrayals
of people so they decided for themselves
they're not going to publish them
anymore that's called
free market capitalism people can
complain or praise a company
and a company can listen to or ignore
those complaints but that's
free market capitalism news by the way
it's not just fox news max also jumping
in on the action
they ran a segment called cancel
culture's next target
dr seuss and then over on fox business
stuart varney running a defiant and
principal segment
simply called dr seuss cancelled
and then lastly well lastly for us i
could go on all day they went on into
the night
this morning they were back on dr seuss
but lastly for
us madison cothorn the trumpian
republican congressman recently accused
by oodles of women of sexual assault
he went on fox news yesterday not asked
about the endless sexual assault
allegations against him
but instead asked about dr seuss
and here is what he said time i'm fired
up about this
i don't know if you are but my guess is
if you had a childhood and you read dr
seuss you might be
president biden canceling dr seuss in a
read across america proclamation this
after loudoun county schools there in
virginia
said his books are filled with quote
orientalism
anti-blackness and white supremacy
look congressman these cancellations get
more and more outlandish by the day when
does this stop
well brother i was going to go to the
gym after this hit but i don't have to
now i'm already fired up that is
absurd you know in inside of our
congress uh
we actually have done a lot we've got a
lot accomplished we have successfully so
far
renamed a post office here in the 117th
congress
so you're telling me that the the actual
priorities of the democrats
is renaming a post office and now
canceling dr seuss
americans are actually struggling
they're really tired of this
but they won't stop covering it all day
day in and day out it continued into the
afternoon
into the evening during the 5 p.m show
on fox called the five
the headline story was six dr seuss
books pulled over offensive images
and what this is is simply what was
going we discussed it yesterday in
detail
some people weren't happy with my
analysis but many people
were and appreciated it they are losing
on every
issue americans think income inequality
is a problem that should be dealt with
americans are more in favor of abortion
being legal in most cases than ever
before
most americans think we should do covet
stimulus and do it the way that joe
biden and democrats have proposed
most americans believe gay marriage
should be legal i'm kind of hopping
around
economic and cultural issues here most
americans believe that there should be
mask wearing for the time being like i
can go on but republicans
are statistically on the wrong side of
every issue so it's dr seuss
all day and andrew cuomo
if they want if they want to do
something that's marginally more
substantive in the way that they cover
it and there is an andrew cuomo story
and we covered it
and that's that's not the argument but
that is what is happening
on fox news at this point i could have
played 10 more clips from yesterday
i could have played five for from today
they will not stop with this issue
and then soon they'll move on to you
know maybe back to
joe biden and jill biden's relationship
is fake that was
uh ten days ago they found a new shiny
object now dr
seuss question for you
do you want me to keep engaging with
this false idea of rampant cancel
culture
or would you prefer i even start
ignoring it
as a critique of what the right is doing
open to hearing from you
today's show is sponsored by an
excellent audiobook
called takeover how a conservative
student club
captured the supreme court this is the
latest audio book from noah feldman it
just came out
and feldman actually narrates the
audiobook himself
noah feldman of course is a harvard law
professor and constitutional scholar
you may remember him from his prominent
role in trump's impeachment number one
and the book takeover looks at how the
federalist society became the most
powerful legal organization in the
country
six of the nine current supreme court
justices
are current or former members of the
federalist society
and takeover dives into what the
organization is what it stands for
its relationship with american politics
the federalist
society is an organization anyone in my
audience
should be aware of and the audiobook has
a ton of excellent insight into it and
the role it plays
i really enjoyed listening to the
audiobook i think anybody
in my audience would as well so grab
takeover by noah feldman the audiobook
is just 4.99
and you can get it at davidpakman.com
takeover or wherever you buy audiobooks